hi everyone yes I have tried very much
to fit in with the desk on pink theme
unfortunately I couldn't find a
hairdresser to dye my hair the perfect
shade of FF 0088 but we'll get there in
the end and so I'm going to be talking
to you today about how to design for
displays that don't exist yet now I work
as a research technologist at the BBC's
R&D department the BBC is the UK's
public broadcaster and not many people
realize that it has an R&D department
but it's the part of the organization
that's responsible for investigating any
kind of new technology that might be of
interest to the broadcasting industry so
that could be anything from new kinds of
cameras to novel distribution methods to
novel web web experiences and I work at
the user experience section which is
towards the end of the broadcasting
chain and we work on short-term projects
such as contributing to industry
standards or enhancing day-to-day BBC
services but also midterm projects that
might reach the audience within a few
years time all the way up to the condom
more futuristic blueSky thinking stuff
which is the kind of thing I'm talking
to you about today and it's gonna the
stuff that I'm talking about is what we
expect to reach the consumer in about 20
years time and I'm part of a small team
currently working on a project called
unconventional screens and we're trying
to anticipate emerging unusual display
technology and create cool user
experience for experiences for them but
because a lot of these displays don't
actually exist yet that can be a little
tricky but before I explain how we've
approached that problem let me remind
you of how the screens we all use have
evolved and hopefully as developers and
designers this will all sound pretty
familiar so going back to the early
2000s people began consuming a lot of
content on the web and everyone was
pretty much using the same device for
this some kind of computer monitor
whether that was a laptop or a desktop
and so that sounds pretty
straightforward but
fortunately browsers played fast and
loose with the rules of interpreting
HTML and JavaScript and that then it was
almost impossible to get your website
looking consistent across all browsers
and that was a problem of cross-browser
compatibility which I'm sure you're all
very familiar is settings began to
improve browsers got a little bit more
sensible about how they interpreted web
content so it finally seemed like things
were getting simpler unfortunately it
wasn't quite so easy just as just as
desktop browsers were getting their act
together people started to use all kinds
of new devices to consume web content so
suddenly developers were having to deal
with mobiles tablets TVs all sorts of
things and because no one wants to look
at a tiny website designed so no wants
to look at our website design for a
giant computer monitor on a tiny mobile
screen suddenly the problem wasn't how
to get the content looking the same
everywhere but how to get content to
optimize for the type of device you're
using and that was the dawn of
responsive design and I'll talk a little
bit more about that later and explain
how we think JavaScript can help push it
even further so I don't want to be the
bringer of bad news but I'm afraid that
this problem is only going to get worse
so we've got things like smartwatches
Google glass oculus rift digital
t-shirts vegetable displays LED flooring
massive video walls smart fridges pico
projectors don't know what that is but
it's pretty cool and screens are getting
weirder so yeah this means we're
designing for getting weirder and
weirder and we all for a few different
sized rectangles was bad so not only are
we going to have to make our content
look beautiful across these
unconventional screens we also need to
think about the kind of content that's
appropriate for each sort of device
because you're probably not going to
want the same sort of content displayed
on your SmartWatch as you do on your
smart wallpaper so that might sound
pretty daunting how on earth can we be
expected to be preparing cool stuff for
these devices when they don't even exist
yet so the first thing is don't panic
there are a few things you can do that
make the process not only a little less
daunting but actually pretty fun because
it should be fun this is the future and
the future is cool
so I'm going to talk you through our
approach to this problem by using our
smart wallpaper project as a case study
and I'll tell you how we went from a
blank sheet of paper to kind of a
working prototype and what we're going
to do with it now that we've built it
and I'm hoping that by sharing the
approach that we find useful you might
go away with some kind of inspiration as
to how to make you or more
unconventional ideas a reality so this
will start with the question what if you
could paper the walls of your home with
flexible electronic wallpaper so that
might sound a bit like science fiction
but if you look at current trends
towards larger displays flexible
displays we reckon that is actually
something that could be pretty likely
within about 20 years time so just to be
clear the BBC aren't trying to actually
physically make the wallpaper that's the
job of manufacturers what we're trying
to do is anticipate and test cool user
experiences that would enrich the lives
of our audience and then we can be ready
for the technology when it emerges and
we're pretty lucky at the BBC because
unlike other companies that have to be
kind of concerned with profit and
proprietary technology we've got the
freedom to focus on providing the best
user experience for our audience
focusing on principles like openness and
innovation so my first tip for you is to
try and take a user experience led
design approach so we let user
experience drive out our ideas and not
the available technology so while
certain companies have done very well
with that in the past the sort of
traditional approach for technology and
engineering companies has been to do it
the other way around so they'll put
loads of time and effort and money into
developing some really cool hardware and
they say right this is great but what
we're going to do with it and a really
good example of that is TV Internet
browsers everyone got really excited
that they had invented TVs that could
connect to the internet and I but they
completely overlooked the user
experience side of things and that meant
that the technology was clunky to use
and provided no additional value to your
TV viewing experience so it just didn't
take off so we're advocating an approach
that has kind of typically been the role
of science fiction it's all about
thinking big and futuristically
demonstrating what you could do with
that stuff if it existed
so in the case of smart wallpaper we
want to show off our prototype in the
hope that this will kind of create an
appetite for the technology pushing
manufacturers into developing it sooner
than they may otherwise have done so
what does this mean in practice you need
to have a really open discussion teasing
out all your ideas no matter how
ridiculous about how the technology
might be used and it's really important
not to censor yourself or anyone else at
that stage you're trying to be as
divergent as possible no idea is too
silly so after we've done that we got
together and converged our ideas down
into the ones that seemed the most
plausible but also most engaging and we
then hired a designer to turn our ideas
into mock-ups and so I'll show you some
of them now so this is what your living
we might look like after you've just
papered it with your plane smart
wallpaper but then you switch on the
television and start watching
Glastonbury and so here we were
experimenting with the concept of
augmenting programs that we broadcast
with extra data and the stuff that at
the moment might clog up the screen but
now I'm kind of pushing it out and
giving the screen more real estate but
we're not just looking at the living
room and this is when we were trying to
think about how smart wallpaper might
apply to a teenager's bedroom so the BBC
provides a lot of educational services
and we began to think about how those
resources might be presented on smart
wallpaper so while this teenagers
revising they can see infographics
relating to whether they're watching on
the computer searching on the computer
and they can scribble notes down on a
device and send them up to the wall once
they finished revising they can turn on
their favorite radio channel and there
will transform giving posters or their
favorite artists a virtual window onto a
live gig and an Instagram feed relating
to whatever they're listening to a lot
of people regularly check BBC weather
and travel updates in the morning and we
figured the best place for that was your
kitchen while you're having breakfast
then when you get back from work we
could use a wall to display steps for
your chosen recipe and you can cook
along with TV chefs back in the living
room somebody is watching a
daytime magazine show so on the wall we
can display a virtual bookcase filled
with books that are being talked about
on the show and virtual picture frames
filled with interesting works of art for
you discuss for you to discuss with your
family and friends another idea we had
was how we might build up anticipation
for a major broadcasting event for
example the 50th anniversary of Doctor
Who so over the space of a few hours or
even a few days you could get your your
whole room to transform to get you into
the mood so in this slide we've got a
virtual window giving you a view out
onto another planet then the doctor
starts appearing in your family
photographs then you get a nice Spacey
wall and then you get scary characters
creeping up on you and then finally
you're transported into the world of
Doctor Who so they're just some of the
ideas that we had when we concentrated
on creating exciting user experiences
and didn't worry too much about whether
they'd be possible or how we do it so
that brings me to the second principle
we try to spit stick to and that is try
to stay agnostic to underlying hardware
we wanted to make sure that anything we
created would work however the
technology evolves in the case of smart
wallpaper we don't know if it's going to
be a touchscreen we don't know if it'd
be a giant video screen whether it'll be
made up of tiles of displays or
something more akin to ink and we
actually think that Ian caption is
probably more likely as it's less
obtrusive than a giant brightly lit
power-hungry monitor but that also makes
it a bit more challenging because we
have to think about the types of content
that would suit a device with low
refresh rates low power and none backlit
but we found that having restrictions
like that actually makes you think a bit
more creatively and we ended up with
more novel use cases than just let's
watch a giant video on the wall so how
do you go about prototyping experiences
trying to remain agnostic to hardware
when you don't know the capabilities of
your technology what's good news for you
we recommend using standard web
technologies so we can be sure that we
can be pretty sure that any new devices
that get developed will be will use
Internet protocols and be web connected
in some way and that's super helpful not
only because we don't have to know
exactly how the technology will evolve
but
also because it means our work will
apply every step step along the way to
getting there so with smart wallpaper
it's going to be a gradual thing we're
not going to leap from nothing to
suddenly your whole room covered in it
people are getting more screens around
the house bigger screen screens in the
kitchen smart mirrors smart windows and
as long as they all have a browser
there's no reason why the experiences
we're creating for smart wallpaper can't
be adapted for those in the meantime so
we wrote our smart wallpaper application
using html5 canvas and JavaScript with a
restful api and a node.js backend and we
spent a lot of time designing the
architecture of the system to make it as
flexible as possible unfortunate don't
have time to go into that now but come
on ask me about it if you're interested
but the point is that using these
technologies means that anything with a
browser can pretend to be a wall given
that browser enabled wallpaper doesn't
exist yet we had to fake it as best as
we could and we use two giant back
projector screens we then connected each
projector to a mac mini and got it to
display a full screen browser we then
prod the server to interact with the
wall and change what's on display so by
that point we had something that
approximates a kind of working a smart
wallpaper working prototype so
yeah I tried to embed it in reveal but
that didn't work so ignore and and the
reason I wanted to show you that was it
is kind of showing you how you can start
off with an idea that seems a bit off
the wall and abstract but by being a bit
resourceful with your prototyping you
can get something that approximates your
goal pretty well and we're a relatively
small team there are only three others
working on it and we've only been doing
it for a few months but because we chose
to use web technologies we were able to
move to prototype really quickly so
what's next for us well we've got a lot
of experimenting to do and some people
find it a bit unusual that we're using
javascript as a language for
experimental research purposes as its
kind of mostly used as a product as a
means for creating user facing products
and that lovers in user experience are
really keen on it and unlike a compiled
language codes code changes are
instantly reflected making it ideal for
rapid prototyping and there are so many
api's and libraries that connect with
novel hardware that comes out that it
means that you can start experimenting
as soon as these things become available
so earlier I mentioned the difficulty of
getting content just to display
appropriately across all kinds of
devices and that as our screens change
that's going to get even trickier so our
next major research area is how we can
use JavaScript to push the concepts of
responsive design so that they can be
applied to unconventional screens so
just to remind you of what we mean by
responsive design responsive websites
provide continuity between different
viewing contexts remaining completely
agnostic to the type of device used and
the size of the screen it has so in the
context of smart wallpaper we don't want
the user to have to manually position
everything they want up on their wall we
need ways of making it automatically the
content automatically flow and fit
around the fat all their furniture and
taking into account the fact that people
have different shapes and sizes of walls
I've got roofs in the way they've got
pictures on them so that it's not just
dealing with rectangles anymore so we
can do a lot of responsive design in CSS
and there are also a lot of JavaScript
libraries like masonry pakery some
jQuery ones and they
a really good job of dynamically packing
rectangular elements into a rectangular
space but unfortunately rectangles are
not enough our unconditional screens can
be all sorts of shapes and sizes as can
the content elements that we want to
appear on them so we need to be
experimenting with new algorithms and
creating more novel JavaScript libraries
so at the moment what we're doing is
building a web based tool for testing
out different layout algorithms and one
promising approach we're looking at is
bin packing and that's an algorithm
that's already widely used for creating
sprite sheets so for those of you who
don't know bin packing is a
computational problem that involves
finding the most efficient way of
packing in different shapes into a sort
of bounding area and it's what's known
as np-hard and that basically means that
there's no kind of straightforward
algorithm to solve it it's basically a
brute force approach and also the
complexity or the sort of size of your
problem increases the complexity is
become it the brute force approach just
becomes unsustainable but there are
certain heuristics that you can use that
sort of help with it like trying to
place the largest shape first and place
a little ones around it but for smart
wallpaper we're not primarily concerned
with fitting as many things on the wall
as we possibly can we're more concerned
about trying to place things in an
aesthetically pleasing way so as
inspiration for how to do that we looked
at some of the ways that people
currently arrange things on their walls
at home and that's actually me to start
thinking about using algorithms that are
used in data visualization so things
like clustering or for space layouts and
wondering whether they could be a good
approach in combination with bin packing
to sort of replicate that human design
input so it's going to be really
interesting to find out for us what
principles we can take from computer
science algorithms like those and apply
them in the context of visual design and
I'm hopefully hopefully going to write a
blog post about our initial thoughts on
that soon so keep an eye out for that if
you're interested and but in the
meantime if anyone fancies having a go
at writing some responsive design
JavaScript libraries for those
algorithms and I'll be really helpful
okay so where does this leave you
screens are changing and as developers
and designers you're probably going to
have to deal with that so start thinking
about how we can create extreme
responsive design taking inspiration
from algorithms that apply in other
contexts but don't panic because
javascript is awesome our team sees it
as a really flexible tool for
prototyping and we reckon it's a pretty
future-proof choice be playful try and
prototype your weird ideas and it's very
men with them and if you want to be
ahead of the curve think about the user
experience and let the technology catch
up with you later and most importantly
watch a load of sci-fi thank you